-Welcome back.
We're hanging out with
the one and only Nicole Kidman!
Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're playing Lucille Ball
in this new movie.
-Yes.
-Now, this is --
How do you go about this?
It is an impression?
No.
You can't do an impression.
-I mean, when Aaron originally
approached me, he was like,
"I do not want you to do an
impersonation of her,"
which, thank God,
because I can't.
I wouldn't be able to.
So, he said, "I really
want to discov--"
I mean, it's about this marriage
and Desi and Lucille.
And I call her Lucille
so that you really can
sort of understand that it's not
the "I Love Lucy" show.
-Yeah, there are two --
the way you did it,
like, "I Love Lucy"
is one character
and then Lucille Ball is --
-Yeah, and Lucille Ball
always said
she as a woman was not funny.
And you would be able
to attest to this --
comedy is hard.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
I thought you were gonna say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What did you think?
-I don't care.
I mean -- I mean --
Yes, comedy is definitely hard.
Yeah.
-Very hard.
-Yes.
-But --
-And it ain't funny right now.
-Oh!
What are you talking about?!
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-But she was one of the best
physical comedians.
-Yeah, and I mean,
for me as an actor,
and primarily a dramatic actor,
I was like, "Oh, my God.
How do you do this?" and...
-You nailed it.
-When I started to study her,
I was like, "oh, I love
playing this woman,"
because the physical comedy
and the movement of the body
and being able to release
into that as an actor
is something I've never done.
-What you did on it
that was fantastic
is that you do Lucy
when the show is on
and your voice is higher,
and you -- "Ricky!"
and you're doing this whole --
-Waaaah!
-Yes. Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
That is that.
Waaah!
And that's what she does.
-Waaah! Waaah!
-And in real life -- yeah.
And in real life when she talks,
she's a smoker --
smoked a lot.
-She had a very deep voice.
She was a heavy smoker.
-Yeah.
I say it when you're not here,
but I'll say it
when you're here --
you're one of the best actors
that ever lived; I love you.
-No.
-Yes, you're amazing.
Everything you're in,
I absolutely buy it.
Hook, line, and sinker, I'm in.
I always go -- You are amazing
in every single thing.
-I love it. I love acting.
I'm very privileged to be able
to do what I love doing.
-You're fantastic.
And please keep doing it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Nicole Kidman
as Lucille Ball
in "Being the Ricardos."
Take a look.
-Act one, interior,
the Ricardos' living room,
night.
-Excuse me. Donald.
-Y-Yes.
-Good morning. I'm Lucille Ball.
-I sure know that, Lucy.
-I wanted to make sure
because you haven't been here
in a while.
Is it because you've been going
through puberty?
-I look young, yes, but I went
through it a long time ago.
And I haven't been here because
I've been directing
at "Danny Thomas."
-With the Communist kid?
[Bleep] off.
-Jesus Christ.
-You don't have to [bleep] off,
but you do need to know
that Danny does jokes --
few people do it better --
I do physical comedy.
-I've seen every episode
of the show.
-So have 60 million
other people.
Are none of them professional
television directors?
-She's kidding.
-I can tell.
-I'm hazing you a little,
Donald.
It's just my way of saying
I have no confidence
in you at all.
-That's it.
Nicole Kidman, everybody.
"Being the Ricardos"
is in theaters December 10th
and available on Prime Video
December 21st.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.